COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we help a food image sharing
service get performance back
on track with custom images.
Like your meals in
30 minutes or less?
Then stay tuned.
Last episode, we got a chance
to work with the Foodie Pics
team who make a social
network that only allows
you to share pictures of food.
No text, no audio, no emoji,
just a picture of food
and the Geolotag of
where it was taken at.
Their application uses Compute
Engine instances to process
and store the uploaded images.
The issue that they've seen is
that their instance boot time
is through the roof, and
causing latency issues when
heavy load is on their system.
Now, we've already profiled
the startup time stages,
as well as a bunch of
random configurations,
and we're able to clearly
eliminate the instance boot
process, chosen image,
and underlying serving
architecture, as potential
bottlenecks for performance,
which means it was
time to start digging
into the code running on the
instance to find the problem.
To do this, we take a
look at the startup script
that Foodie Pics was using.
Once a new instance was
created, their very first step
of their app was to execute
a startup script, which
installed various services
and code libraries that
would allow the
instance to function
and be accessible externally.
Their script was
significantly more complex,
but it generally looks
something like this.
Clearly, though, we
needed to figure out
what stage of this script was
causing the performance burden.
Now, profiling a startup
script is a weird exercise.
A, how do we get
the timing data,
and B, how do we return that
so that we can test it later?
For the first problem,
I'm working in Linux
and dealing with bash scripts.
So the seconds command
works just fine,
wrapping it around each one
of the sections in the script.
For the second problem
of reporting the data,
there's lots of options here.
Chances are that you've got code
that already takes advantage
of powerful tool systems
like Statsd or Brubeck,
but for my purposes,
that would require
pulling down yet
another package,
not to mention the time required
in starting those services
before I'd be able to use them.
So I'll skip that for now.
On the other hand, the
Stackdriver custom metrics API
might work.
See, all GCE instances come
pre-installed with access
to write to this API,
so that would get rid
of the need to bring
down new packages
or host complex back ends.
Sadly, though,
writing to the API
requires some complexity,
namely authentication,
which I'm not willing to put
forth effort into right now.
So we'll skip that.
For this case, I did something
much more hack-tastic,
store the timings in a file and
serve them as a new endpoint.
This allowed me to
pull the endpoint
from an external location
and get back my data
without too much heavy lifting.
Here is a graph showing the
timings for each section
as 100 iterations of
timing the startup script.
It's clear to see in the
graph that the time per stage
of the startup script
doesn't fluctuate
too much between tests.
It's somewhere between
60 and 75 seconds.
No one stage clearly stands
out as a performance problem.
Really, it's the aggregation
of all the stages
that's creating an issue.
Doing some more digging
with the Foodie Pics' CTO,
it became clear that they
only updated those scripts
about once or twice a month at
this point, so the content they
were pulling down was mostly
static, which pointed almost
immediately to their problem.
See, each time a new
instance is spun up,
they're pulling down
almost identical content.
The change is on,
maybe, a monthly basis.
They're basically wasting
a minute of cold boot time
to do the same thing over,
and over, and over again,
which means we can
leverage custom images.
A custom image,
or image snapshot,
is basically a snapshot of
the host disk information
after everything has
already been installed.
When a target VM is booted,
the image information
is copied right
to the hard drive.
No need to go grab all
that data one at a time
and install thousands
of files from the net.
As soon as you boot
up the new instance,
you're just paying for
the performance cost
of installing the image itself.
For Foodie Pics, this was a
huge performance improvement.
They were able to make
a custom image with most
of the big packages
installed, but still allowed
a small startup script
that pulled down
the server front-end code.
The result was moving
from a boot time
in minutes down to one
measured in subseconds.
And just a note, even though
we're using a custom image,
the boot phase of installing
their image really
didn't fluctuate much,
which is fantastic,
considering that we're not only
installing our core operating
system, but also a
bunch of other software
which was previously pulled
down via network commands.
The Foodie Pics team ran
into a very common problem
for most developers.
Once you reach a certain level
of complexity in your startup
scripts, the cold boot
time of your application
starts to suffer, at which
point it's a great idea
to consider using custom
images to bring down your boot
time to something normal.
So, if you're interested in
more Cloud Performance goodness,
make sure to check out the rest
of our videos and remember,
when it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]